Troy is with us in Kansas hey Troy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey hello Dave
hey what's up hey I been struggling I
work a full-time job and I live paycheck
to paycheck I have a married and three
kids all under the age of four and my
wife she just stay at home mom she does
the budgeting and why make money and
we're still coming up for somehow and I
don't know what we're doing wrong okay
how old are you guys yeah 25 okay what
do you make a year around 42,000 okay
how much debt have you got not counting
your house I'm actually I filed
bankruptcy about a year and a half ago
so I'm still going through that I still
have though about a thousand dollars in
debt that's about out there which is
medical bills which I can add to the
bankruptcy now you're in a chapter 13
paying payments yes for five years
correct yeah and how much is your
chapter 13 payment a month I pay $100 a
month for that and how much debt is
there in the chapter 13 I'm a little bit
over 22,000 what's at home mainly
medical and I had a $8,000 car and it
was a bad decision was that a repo or
yeah they got repo'd okay so you're
paying on the repo you're paying on
medical and you got a new thousand
dollar medical who's so sick um it was
just me I had some health issues in and
out and you don't have health insurance
um I did but it didn't cover 100% of
everything no it doesn't okay and you
don't savings to cover so your
deductibles and your co-pays or what
added up correct yeah okay all right
well um number one you're not doing a
whole bunch of stuff wrong
you're probably just fairly normal I
mean you make $45,000 you're 25 years
old with three kids to feed there's no
room in this budget much it's not like
you're right you know one little blink
like a little medical event or one
little blink like buying a car you can't
afford and all of a sudden you've got a
real problem and so it's not like you
were did something that was super super
stupid you just had no wiggle room and
tried to wiggle no I mean that's just
where you are so the answer to the
equation is to get more detailed and
better at doing a budget with your wife
I make the money and she does the budget
doesn't work the two of you she can do
the budget but then the two of you need
to sit down and go over it and we need
to have a detailed plan of how we're
going to live every single month each
month on paper on the money that is
coming in or less than the money that's
coming in and you're not you're not
doing that now you're bringing home the
check and she's making it go as far as
she can possibly go and she's not doing
too bad a job but it's not great it's
not great because it's leaving you all
vulnerable to every little wiggle does
this sound right right yeah that's so
what I want to do first and foremost is
dial up the the quality of the budgeting
exercise that you and your wife are
doing together and then the sticking to
that budget that you do together because
if you don't you're not gonna wiggle out
of this you're not gonna accidentally
wake up one morning go I won the
Superbowl it no one accidentally wins so
you really got to do lots and lots and
lots of detail
now that's thing one thing too is what
do you do for a living
all right look at utilities okay and
you're 25 what do you wanna be doing
when you're 35 that pays $100,000 a year
no well my goal is I want to get into
either law enforcement a fire that's
that's the goal how are you doing what
he's doing to get there I'm right now
I'm gonna volunteer firefighter how to
send how does that interested they will
pay for my for me to go get my EMT
schooling
yet other schooling bill that my
department pays for it not many
departments do that
what is your EMT what does an EMT make
in your area
I don't they don't kind of look that far
into that I don't know I think I'd want
to know before I went to school cuz you
make 45 now if they make 38 you don't
want to do this okay
that makes sense hey yes your goal
changes because you don't want your
dream to be a nightmare so let's let's
detail out where we're going I'm
thinking that an EMT depending on what
area of Kansas you're in how rule the
setting is but an EMT in your area
probably makes 50 or 60 that's my guess
and so then the next question is when
you're going to school at a tech school
I know when when my goal is to go here
in January okay get into night classes
what I'm working full-time that's it
good see what I'm saying is we have to
have a goal to not make 45 or will
always make 45 right and you've you've
got some steps laid out in front of you
to get to that goal that's good good
planning well done and so you just got
to start dialing this stuff in and go
okay what I kind of do to get may and
come up on the short term what can I do
to get my income up in the long term and
and let's manage the money that we have
super super super tight and you know
though the last pieces is what can she
do from home while taking care of three
kids that can add a little bit of money
to this equation and so I'm going to do
two things for you I want the two of you
to go through our class and our one-year
membership financial piece and we'll put
you in the Financial Peace University
class which will detail out exactly how
to handle money but also exactly how to
do this budget and how to handle that
every dollar app which is included in
this and I'm giving it all to your free
okay all right and I'm also gonna send
her wife a copy of the book business by
boutique by Christie ripe
equiping women to make money doing what
they love lots of ladies find things
they can do from home that make serious
Bank while watching their kids it's not
that unusual if you're like me your
wife's smarter than you are so you
might be able to make more than you
while watching the three kids it's
possible so you know yeah because here's
the deal you've got you've got a below
average household income not way below
you're not at the poverty level you're
only 25 so that's not unusual but the
average household income in America is
fifty-nine thousand and that that's
statistical data that is not my opinion
and so what you got to do is say what am
I going to do to get above average to
have above average financial results and
so the the mess that you find yourself
in Troy is not because you're a stupid
person you are not a stupid person
you're dealing with limited means you're
a young dad trying to pull this off and
you've done a pretty dadgum good job
even though you've made a few mistakes
here and there
I'll talk to people everyday including
myself who have done Dumber things and
you've done so you're not doing too bad
you plug into this you get in this
financial piece with your wife tell her
to get in that book and let's figure out
a way to make some money and let's let's
go onward and upward my brother this is
the Dave Ramsey show